hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Mary
Russell Mary Russell new to the channel
met her on Brandis after party for the
Joker Harley Quinn thinks she shot him I
don't think you guys know about it but
anyway she's a horror movie director and
writer as well she wrote and directed
this short film called carved I saw the
trailer it's a really good trailer you
could check it out there's a link right
here there's a link in the description
box seriously check out the trailer we
might be doing something together for
this channel so yeah
collaboration collaboration making
horror things together
speaking of horror we're gonna check out
from Screen Rant today movie creatures
that will give you nightmares let's see
what their list is
what Alabang who doesn't love a good
movie monster it's almost second nature
Nosferatu to the beast from 20,000
fathoms the world of cinema has a
monster to suit the tastes of every
viewer no tools can make free man
there's a waste of good suffering
anyone can make a movie about a vampire
call it a monster but it takes some real
talent to craft an abomination that
exceeds the minds of audiences for life
here are screen rants 10 movie creatures
that will give me make things the Palin
hands lab yeah yeah that Oh buddy
working in film today knows what makes
monsters frightening better than
guillermo del toro the proof the pale
man from Pan's Labyrinth
a loose skin child eating creature
encountered halfway through the film the
pale man sits at a dining room table
laden with a feast meant to tempt up
Toros protagonist Ofelia she enters the
pale manslayer with instructions not to
eat anything she sees summary sheets to
juice the pale man gives chase and
viewers are right next to her throughout
the tear I'm so scary
ah come out the room well it's bring me
out Japanese horror set a lasting trend
with its release after films like scream
the faculty and Bride of Chucky soured
us on slasher flicks samara was a
ghostly breath of fresh air her
appearance and creaky gate made
audiences skin crawl
and the film's most famous sequence
crawls out of intelligence the low and
mid brain in the ancient also mean
mostly sorry wish they had kept their
iceberg Zeena emailing good start the
Alien franchise deserves a high spot on
this list
despite the clones it's still one of the
most original and iconic movie monsters
to date beware you might think you're
looking at some exposed piping in a
spaceships wall but look again the
spiked tail and terrifying mouth tongue
thing can strike in an instant
by the time you recognize the xenomorph
for what it truly is it's already too
late
yeah Jennifer Ken treated an
indescribable antagonist an RSI between
a claim debut the baggage whatever form
it chooses to take it's always just the
right amount oh don't be fooled by the
creatures cartoonish exterior mister in
its name the minimalist design cast an
unforgettable image that will not leave
your head once you see it what our
mother Amelia that's the babadook into
her head where he makes himself at home
and terrorizes both her and her son
Aquila vomit monster poltergeist - I'm
mr. Nelson's character gets drunk and
ends up swallowing a worm that's been
possessed by the Beast formerly known as
Reverend Henry the Beast then possesses
Steve after struggles Steve expels the
word which grows bigger and grosser by
the second before turning into a
nightmarish writhing tentacle work the
neverending story brush motion move so
Wolfgang Petersen's the neverending
story as a child look back on the
adventure with fondness and nostalgia ah
they might also recall the many nights
they spent wide awake in bed frozen in
fear unable to get the leering grin of
the nihilistic werewolf Mork out of
their minds the neverending story is not
a scary movie by any means but morgue on
the other hand is an incredibly scary
monster
safe to say he's responsible for more
than his fair share of nighttime terrors
human mutant Nazis an American Werewolf
in London these incredible creatures
crop up in a nasty dream sequence
partway through John Landis is werewolf
movie David Kessler survives an attack
that leads his friend Jack dead in a
dream David and his family enjoying
evening at home that's interrupted by
demonic beasts unmistakeably wearing
nazi uniforms haha they execute mom dad
and younger siblings before killing him
dream is packed with meaning but most of
all the monsters managed to be as
memorable as the film's real star anise
it's just an accomplishment in itself
hello that movie Freddy Krueger and
Nightmare on Elm Street
any list with the word nightmare in its
title probably has space for the king of
nightmares himself he might not get the
monster category but he's definitely
monstrous and avoids is he know his way
around the bed otherwise she also knows
how to have fun though his idea of fun
tends to be fatal for everyone involved
Freddy can't harm his victims in person
it is creative and he gets his amusement
from suffering unlike his emotionless
mask 1980 slasher film competition other
maniacs kill and move on but Freddy
takes his time to get every ounce of
terror and laughter out of each kill
Freddy the chatter hello no ransom for
those who view the dentist's chair as
the most terrifying to consumer you can
watch every single film in the
Hellraiser franchise and pick any number
of unwholesome themes from each and most
would fit the criteria of this list but
the Chatterer set stomachs twisting with
a single glimpse he's the definition of
grotesque with packing teeth and a
straight face the very sight of it means
that your number is up and you're off to
an eternity of torment
everybody's disturbing you
brundlefly the plum butterfly is the
horrible end result of a series of
unfortunate scientific experiments in
David Cronenberg's the fly but it's
simpler just to say he's downright gross
it's not set Grendel's fault he winds up
as this monstrosity no only nature cost
in his ability to resist seth responds
to his most primal urges he puts an
arm-wrestling opponent in a sling and
dissolves another man's hand and ankle
with corrosive vomit if sets plan to
turn himself his lover veronica and
their unborn child into a single entity
wasn't the last straw the melting and
the puking probably would have been so
what do you think varlets did you miss
any nightmarish movie features let us
know in a comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos like this one
I'm not Aziz the horror as you are I've
seen in most of those films but just
seeing like a bunch of the images of
like their creepiest ones from those
movies I like the gore of him taking off
the nail that was my favorite in the fly
yeah dude I hate nail stuff then now
torture and torture torture porn why are
you into that huh I know me
uh-uh dude no man a nail falling off
isn't too [ __ ] much for me dude
I know that fly I remember watching that
I saw that when I was young and I
thought was a fantastic movie it's one
of those Creature Features that's like
genuinely like a classic in my opinion I
think it's like a great Hollywood film
overall not just a horror film but just
uh oh great put together yes the
wonderfully put together film Jeff
Goldblum's great in a do you see pans
library no oh you miss Pan's Labyrinth
I've even seen Pan's Labyrinth I'm smart
it's in Spanish
I saw with the English subtitles but I
understood it that creature
I remember watching on the theatres and
I was flipping out every time that
creature got the pale monster got closer
and closer to the main character freak
me the [ __ ] out because it's got
eyeballs in this again yeah that's what
I know that I was like one thing I
noticed about this list every one of the
creatures practical effects it's all
practical it's not visual effects yeah
we need to get back to a day and age
that's really about practical effects
I'm surprised that they didn't mention
more of the classic horror films like
with werewolf or Dracula or Nosferatu I
mean they they mention it a little bit
in the beginning but they didn't touch
base on that like in the video right so
that's kind of surprise event but I feel
like the creatures they chose are are
more frightening yeah that's true that's
true and they were able to describe it
yeah I'm more of a classic girl gosh as
you can tell masks and then of the ring
the ring the [ __ ] ring ring the
[ __ ] ring I remember that one
us I can't that out so much so I thought
that was one of those movies that I saw
I must live in him like eighth grade or
something and when I saw that movie I
had those images in my mind and wherever
I went I would just imagine that [ __ ]
girl appearing like my mirror you know
what the worst is when I were gonna take
a [ __ ] and I thought I'd be in the
shower like oh [ __ ] I should have
checked the curtains open them before
taking a [ __ ] because now I'm scared
that she's gonna appear when I first
moved here I lived in Tarzana and I had
cable and I didn't have Netflix or any
of that stuff and every single time I
turned the TV it would have that effect
and I just can't I can't do it I can't
okay when you finally see your face oh
yeah our face is terrifying it's like
she people have compared me to her which
I don't know that appeared to that that
is not nice I know like they're like you
know Mary you kind of remind me of not
cool not cool you should never tell
someone that no but I see what they mean
I'm just jokin Angelica I'm just joking
well I can see that the classic alien
yeah that's my trick yeah you know when
I went to the Mesa Universal Studio know
I was about to mention that actually
that was my favorite new was my favorite
on the predator an alien way yeah and
the alien seeing it the design
especially the Queen alien yeah was
[ __ ] scary thing my thing I've seen
all these movies but seen in real life
was like way more scary
I love the hoenn Horror Nights version
of that it's like that the interactions
and the what are they called where they
laugh interior others like squeal yeah
yeah like five people in a car had those
things yeah absolutely I can say by the
way I'm gonna Halloween Horror Nights in
October so um I'll let you know what
date I'm going you guys should meet up
yeah she meet up we should meet up I
never caught poltergeist ooh did you see
I did not see that movie but that worm
looks absolutely it makes me kind of
want to watch the movie yeah I would
watch it as I don't I don't know what
the general overall consensus is of how
people feel about poltergeist - I don't
know if people like he gets like one of
those [ __ ]
sequels or not yeah the effects there
looks really good then those look pretty
amazing
those look like practical yeah so it's I
mean I'm very impressed I'm very
impressed
what's absolutely disgusting Freddy
Krueger Krueger is one of the more
interesting creatures to me that they
chose for this list because yeah really
a creature yeah he's not really
creatures are human he's a burn victim
like ghost anomaly I don't know what the
[ __ ] he is but he's more of a dream
sequence and he comes to you and your
dreams and he's supposed to be a
nightmare yeah I'm not supposed to be a
creature but I could see at the same
time why they put him on the list
because what makes him feel that way is
the terror he creates you know yeah I
think that's yeah I think that's
understandable I think that they should
have included more of the classic people
again like Frankenstein and stuff like
that yeah well like rights are universal
that's where Universal yeah these I'm
assuming more general alien-like
creature is that America Lee yeah I'm
assuming these are more for an audience
today that would be scared of me yeah
yes I know when they first showed
Frankenstein like people were running
out of the theater yeah yeah I'm
screaming but nowadays you show Frank's
I know and really give a [ __ ] like you
know fix the creature from Hellraiser
though I don't know yeah oh god I was
grow the [ __ ] it looks like it looks
like a vagina with like really bad STDs
that part of the STD is you grow teeth
that let me take a photo of this one
shot this is the vagina that we're
talking about right here
oh my god yeah it looks like it looks
like someone had a penis and then
someone counted them and tried
surgically long night of [ __ ] have
you seen teeth yeah sorry very very
similar to what it looks yeah what I
imagine it would look like cuz they
don't show it and this is a really gross
image yeah that is disgusting beautiful
brilliant I love how [ __ ] practical
effects do that to you man I recently
got braces so that like makes me feel
like oh yeah I can imagine
that's that's how a mad
did when I first got braces what it
wouldn't look okay we're human being
mm-hmm guys are new the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects um you can
check out the trailer for Mary
short-film carved carve looks good it's
like a grind house kind of feel yeah
check it out looks really good for hot
chicks bad guy who knows what's gonna go
down and you could follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine periscope she has
a Facebook fan page too Mary Russell
check it out they're like cool photos on
there yeah yeah of me in my underwear
really you're in your underwear yeah um
well your boyfriend get upset if we just
quickly follow it right now yeah just
now you up and just quickly look at it
alright Mary um scroll down scroll down
not bow on my bow on that one
oh wow wow you're a redhead at one point
okay this is good this is good stuff
this is this is very context is great
content more people will like you now
more people will respect you I guess
I'll get more respect on on my page okay
you need just more photos like that and
everyone's gonna have a good to go
everyone's gonna end up liking your act
like this is this is great stuff this is
fantastic imagery anyway good job thanks
thanks I know how to advertise I know
how to market you know I really do